Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass in der 2. Männer-Bundesliga. Da haben es drei Aufsteiger bisher geschafft, für auch positive Geschichten zu sorgen. Damit wollen wir uns heute befassen, hier in Rasenfunk Kurzpass, Nummer 248. Ich begrüße euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Wie schon angekündigt, widmen wir uns heute der 2. Männer-Bundesliga. Zeit wird es. Und heute haben wir eine Aufsteigerrunde hier. Deshalb begrüße ich hier bei mir Anna Lautenbach von der Plattform 210 und dem Eintracht Braunschweig-Podcast Gegengerade. Sie ist die Edrosa Laut. Wer ihr nicht folgt auf allen solchen Mieterplattformen, der hat sie nicht mehr alle. Und sie hat dann dementsprechend nicht alle Follower. Das war jetzt komisch. Hallo Anna, schön, dass du hier bist. Ebenfalls hier, ihr kennt ihn vom Podcast Neues vom Krügelplatz. Ihr kennt ihn aus dem NDR und auch schon aus dem Rasenfunk. Er ist der Ed Leisteo und dieses Akronym steht für Oliver Leiste. Hallo Olli, schön, dass du hier bist. Wir werden heute über Magdeburg sprechen und seitdem ich diese Tasse habe. Das war, glaube ich, unsere erste Folge, wo ich immer noch Magdeburg gesagt habe und du zu höflich warst, mich zu korrigieren. Und dann hat mir ein Hörer eine – es heißt Magdeburg – Tasse geschickt.
Da sind die FCM-Fans sehr hinterher, dass ihre Stadt und ihr Verein richtig ausgesprochen werden.
Ach du, für mich ist eine Tasse bei rausgesprungen, deswegen möchte ich mich an der Stelle nicht verschweren. Da habe ich schon unangenehmeres Feedback bekommen. Ebenfalls unangenehmes – nein, eigentlich nur angenehmes – Feedback gab es, als das letzte Mal Moritz Kreilinger hier war, vom Kicker der Edm-Kreilinger bei Twitter. Wir hatten allerdings da weniger schöne Themen. Wir haben auch über Lautern gesprochen, aber auch viel über Inservenzen. Schön, dass du hier bist, Moritz, und schön, dass wir heute auch über anderes sprechen können.
Ich freue mich auch über sportliche Themen rund um den FCK mal mit euch zu sprechen.
Ja, und damit würde ich tatsächlich ganz gerne starten, denn ich gucke mir nach diesem 23. Spieltag die 2. Männer-Bundesliga an. Und dann liegt da der 1. FC Kaiserslautern auf dem 6. Tabellenplatz, 1 Punkt hinter Rang 4. Zugegeben, es sind schon in Anführungszeichen 8 Punkte hinter Rang 3. Aber trotzdem, Moritz, was zur Hölle ist da denn bitte los?
Ja, wir haben gerade gesagt, ich freue mich über positive Dinge in Kaiserslautern zu sprechen. Und dann muss ich dir leider sagen, Max, dann bist du einen knappen Monat zu spät. Weil hätten wir Anfang Februar gesprochen, hätten wir sie noch in den Himmel heben können. Aber nach zuletzt 3 Niederlagen aus 4 Spielen ist die Frage, was ist da los, durchaus angebracht. Und um es irgendwie kurz zu fassen, sie sind so ein bisschen aus ihrem Flow rausgekommen. Und das hat verschiedene Gründe.
Ja, aber lass mal erst mal einen positiven Anfang, weil das ist mir schon durchaus auch bewusst, dass Lauten schon mal ein bisschen besser da stand und dass man jetzt eben 3 der letzten 4 Spiele verloren hat. Ich habe mich auch durchaus schon über das Timing, diese Schwerwugend geärgert. Da dachte ich mir auch so, da habe ich ein bisschen zu lange gewartet. Aber lass erst mal mit dem Positiven beginnen. Also was auch hier im Rasenfunk schon besprochen war, war der Saisonstart war gar nicht so schlecht, haben wir ja auch mitbekommen. Dann gab es diese Unentschieden-Serie, wo Unentschieden aller Art mit dabei waren. Also ein 4-4 gegen Magdeburg, 0-0 gegen Sandhausen, 3-3 gegen Darmstadt, ein 2-2 gegen Heidenheim. Also es war sehr einfach, dann irgendwann zu tippen. Auch ein 1-1 gegen Braunschweig, dann haben wir jetzt hier alle beteiligten Vereine hier genannt. Aber dann haben sich diese Unentschieden irgendwann in Siege verkehrt. Was waren denn da die Erfolgsfaktoren beim FCK?
Ja, es hat ja schon in der Zeit der Unentschieden gar nicht so viel dazu gefehlt, dass du die Spiele gewonnen hättest. Gerade du hast dieses Vieresspiel gegen Magdeburg angesprochen, dieses Vier zu Vier, das hin und her ging. Da am Start lagen sie auch bis zum Schluss relativ lange noch vorne und am Ende den bitteren Ausgleich kassiert. Letztendlich kam dann die Phase, wo das Matchglück wieder auf Seiten des FCKs gelegen hat. Beispiel 17. Spieltag vor Thuner Düsseldorf 1 zu 1 bis zur Nachspielzeit und in 90 plus X dann doch noch der umjubelte Siegtreffer. Von der Art und Weise, wie die Spiele gelaufen sind, haben sie sich in diesem Zeitraum gar nicht so viel genommen. Mal war das Matchglück mehr da, mal war es weniger da und das hat häufig dann den Unterschied gemacht, ob letztlich drei Punkte oder ein Punkt rausgesprungen sind.
Und als wir das letzte Mal hier drüber gesprochen hatten über den FCK, da wurde viel über die Transfers gesprochen von den damaligen Gästen. Da wurden Lute und Clement genannt und natürlich viel der Name Terence Boyd. Das ist jetzt nicht so komplett überraschend. Waren es dann jetzt auch in den letzten Monaten die entscheidenden Spiele?
Ja, Terence Boyd ist natürlich – hätte Kaiserslautern Terence Boyd nicht, um es mal so zu sagen, hätten sie ein großes Problem. Weil allein mit seiner Präsenz, die er vorne reinbringt, er ist groß, er ist wuchtig, hat eine unheimliche Physik, ist gleichzeitig aber auch schnell und hat eine Dynamik, die man ihm auf den ersten Blick gar nicht so sehr zutraut. Und er hat seine Tore einfach gemacht. Und er ist für Kaiserslautern einfach dieser Anker, den du vorne im Spiel immer wieder suchen kannst, sowohl was Bälle ablegen, was Anspielstationen verpässe, was Flanken angeht, was Steilschicken angeht. Ich glaube, es gibt kaum einen Stürmer in dieser 2. Liga, der dieses Paket wirklich so mitbringt wie Terence Boyd. Und ansonsten ist es eine Vielzahl von Faktoren. Ich glaube, Andreas Lute ist in der meisten Zeit der Ruhefaktor, die Sicherheit, die du dir erhoffst. Er hat aber auch schon den einen oder anderen Patzer drin gehabt. Und Philipp Klemernd ist wie andere auch so ein bisschen mit Licht und Schatten. Spielerisch natürlich für die 2. Liga ein super guter Spieler, keine Frage. Aber gerade wenn es um kämpferische Komponenten geht und die Arbeit gegen den Ball, ist das ein oder andere Defizit.
Jetzt ist es ja aber so. Vielleicht erinnern sich da gar nicht mehr alle so genau dran. Aber wenn wir uns mal angucken, wie jetzt eigentlich eure drei Teams hier aufgestiegen sind, ich sage jetzt einfach mal eure, dann war Lautern ja dasjenige, das sich gerade noch so reingeschoben hat. Gab es ja auch noch Trainerwechsel und so weiter und so fort. Ich denke, wenn Trainer, sollte man gleich auch noch ein Wort verlieren. Aber souveräner Meister der 3. Liga war ja Olli Magdeburg. An dich deshalb die einfache Frage. Auch weil jetzt Magdeburg 2 zu 0 gegen Kaiserslautern gewonnen hat am letzten Spieltag. Erkennst du den FCK wieder, wenn du ihn mit dieser 3. Liga-Saison vergleichst?
Na ja, ein Stück weit schon. Diese Körperlichkeit, die haben sie sich behalten. Sie haben ja dann auch Terence Boyd dazu bekommen im Winter. Der war ja davor in Halle. Und das ist vielleicht noch ganz spannend, weil ich eigentlich, als er 2000, man war das 19, nach Halle kam, da war seine Karriere ja fast auch schon so ein bisschen vorbei. Da war er in verschiedenen Stationen in Deutschland gewesen, wo er nicht so richtig gut funktioniert hat. Dann war er in den USA, da hat er jetzt auch nicht wahnsinnig viele Tore geschossen. Und dann haben sie ihn in Halle geholt und plötzlich hat er genau das gesagt, was der Moritz gerade gesagt hat, genau das gemacht, einfach einen Haufen Tore gemacht, war präsent, war schnell und war aber auch so ein Gesicht des Vereins und einer, der aber auch voran marschiert ist, der irgendwie so die Zeichen gesetzt hat. Und das Gefühl, das habe ich eben bei Kaiserslautern jetzt auch. Und insofern denke ich, wenn man die Mannschaft aus dem Winter nimmt, vom letzten Winter Kaiserslautern, würde ich jetzt sagen, haben sie sich gar nicht so viel verändert. Also sie waren vorher defensiv schon gut. Vorne haben sie nicht so sonderlich viele Tore gemacht, das haben sie mit Terence Boyd geändert. Und dabei sind sie eigentlich geblieben, wenn ich das jetzt aus der Ferne so beurteilen kann.
Das klingt alles so wahnsinnig einfach. Und Anna, wie ist es für dich? Braunschweig hat damals als Zweiter aufgestiegen, knapp vor Lautern. Wenn du es mal vergleichst mit der 3.
Liga.
Was genau vergleiche?
Also ist Lautern für dich quasi einfach nur eine 3. Liga-Mannschaft, die sehr erfolgreich weiterspielt? Oder hat sich was verändert?
Nee, es hat sich schon verändert. Was ich relevant wahrnehme, was Kaiserslautern vielleicht als Gesamtverein, also Mannschaft, Verein, Vereinsumfeld und Fans unterscheidet. Vor allem von Braunschweig. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie es in Magdeburg aussieht. Es ist halt dieser gefühlte Knall, der da im Sommer passiert ist. Dass es plötzlich nach vorne ging und dass alle Bock hatten auf die 2. Liga, dass diese krassen Transfers getätigt worden sind, die nicht nur aus sportlicher Perspektive interessant waren, sondern auch einfach ganz cooles Storypotenzial bieten, Rückkehrer. Man möchte den Verein wieder nach vorne bringen und so weiter und so fort. Ich finde, das hat so etwas Visionäres. Hier entsteht jetzt wieder was Großes. Die sportliche Qualität – dafür habe ich nicht genug Spiele gesehen von Kaiserslautern. Das kann ich nicht bewerten, glaubt das aber natürlich. Sie ist ja auch in der Tabelle, dass das irgendwie ganz gut funktioniert alles in einem. Aber wenn ich es vergleiche mit meinem Aufsteiger, habe ich irgendwie eher den Eindruck, dass da im Sommer irgendwie was freigesetzt worden ist, was noch weiter Richtung vorne gehen wird.
Da hat ja Terence Boyd auch neulich so einen Satz gesagt, so sinngemäß, momentan macht sich keiner mehr über den ersten FC Kaiserslautern lustig. Und das fand ich sehr bemerkenswert, weil das ja das Bild war, was ich von dem Verein in der 3. Liga hatte. Und ihr hattet ja auch im Rasenfunk die lange Folge, wo ihr eben über die Insolvenz und den langen Weg in die Insolvenz gesprochen habt. Und wo ich ehrlich sagen muss, aus einer Fanperspektive fand ich den FC K in der 3. Liga auch richtig scheiße und habe den, er hätte den ehrlicherweise auch den Abstieg gegönnt, weil die kurz vor der Insolvenz waren. Und dann von, weiß ich nicht, von Jena oder von Dresden oder ich hab's jetzt nicht mehr alles im Kopf, Spieler geholt haben, wo dann die Transfersum nicht bezahlt wurden und solche Sachen. Also da muss ich wirklich sagen, habe ich dem FC K in der Zeit wirklich alles schlechter eigentlich gegönnt, was da so passiert ist. Und dann haben sie sich eben da wieder herangeschoben, waren dann irgendwo mit im Aufstiegsrennen dabei, aber jetzt eben auch nicht mit begeisterndem Fußball. Und da finde ich es schon spannend, so diese Aussage von Terence Boyd, weil ich das genauso empfinde. Und jetzt auch wieder denke, es macht, auch wenn man nicht Fan von Kaiserslautern ist, irgendwie Spaß, sich mit denen zu beschäftigen. Und da würde ich mich auch Anna anschließen. Sportlich kann ich das jetzt nicht so genau einschätzen, aber dieses Bild hat sich komplett gewandelt und das finde ich einfach total spannend.
Ich finde, Anna, du hast eben was ganz Interessantes gesagt und damit einen wichtigen Punkt getroffen. Es hat so einen Knall gegeben auch in Kaiserslautern und alles war wieder gut. Ich glaube, dass gerade dieser Punkt mit, du bist kurz vor Saisonende noch Zweiter und hast auf der Zielgeraden diesen direkten Aufstiegsplatz verspielt und auf einmal musst du in die Relegation. Gerade rund um diesen Club hat diese Relegation jeder als eine Strafe angesehen und gar nicht mehr als eine Chance. Die ganze Stimmung war am Boden und es hat auch Dirk Schuster damals gesagt, als er gekommen ist, sowas hat er eigentlich noch nicht erlebt. Eine Mannschaft hat eine Chance, irgendwie in zwei Spielen, jetzt in die zweite Liga aufzusteigen und die Stimmung ist total, total am Boden und ja, da konnte sich wirklich alles noch mal so konzentrieren und dann hast du dir in diesen zwei Spielen dann auch noch mal einen ausverkauften Betzenberg und dann natürlich auch dieses Spiel in Dresden, wo natürlich auch Emotionen und alles in der Luft lag und dann dadurch, dass du dir diesen Aufstieg über diesen Weg erkämpft hast, war diese ganze Stimmung im Sommer noch mal eine ganz andere, als wenn du irgendwie auf der Zielgeraden dich gerade noch so vielleicht über den zweiten Platz gerettet hast hättest.
Ja, obwohl ich jetzt nicht sagen kann, dass der zweite Platz in Braunschweig für die großen Sommergefühle gesorgt hat.
Ja, ihr hättet auch über die Relegation gehört, das hat er doch gerade erklärt.
Ja, aber dafür können wir nichts. Ich meine, wir haben, glaube ich, auch eher davon profitiert, dass Kaiserslautern halt ein unfassbar schlechtes Saisonfinish abgeliefert hat. Aber das liegt ja nicht in unserer Verantwortung. Nichtsdestotrotz ein Aufstieg auf der Couch und damit einhergehend auch ein Fragezeichen, zumindest gefühlt, hinter der Legitimation dieser sportlichen, dieses sportlichen Emporgeklommen, also geklettert. Ja, hat es alles, ich weiß nicht genau, war nicht so richtig cool. Wir hatten nicht diese Meistereuphorie in Magdeburg, aber auch nicht diesen Rausch nach einer gewonnenen Relagation. Zwei Spiele, in denen das um alles geht, kann ich mir vorstellen, dass das noch mal eine heftige Energie kanalisiert.
Ja, und gleichzeitig hast du vorhin was gesagt, Moritz, wo ich mir dachte, als wir da im Tribüngespräch drüber geredet haben, wenn wir uns im Tribüngespräch um irgendwelche Leute gegen die Vision hatten für den FCK, dann hat es immer zu was Schlechtem geführt, nämlich zu mehr Schulden und dann lief wieder irgendwas schief und man hat versucht, an eine glorreiche Vergangenheit anzuknüpfen, die immer weiter in Fahne gerückt ist. Was ist denn oder ist diesmal was anderes und von wem kommen diese Visionen überhaupt?
Ja, Thomas Hengen hat es seit seiner Amtsübernahme im März 2021. Er hat es einfach geschafft, diesen Verein wieder zu einigen. Es ist nicht mehr jeder gegen jeden, sondern es ist einfach ein Miteinander geworden. Ich muss sagen, ich war damals skeptisch, als Thomas Hengen den Posten übernommen hat. Seine Erfahrung in Führungspositionen dieser Art war relativ begrenzt. Er war vorher nur bei Alemannia Aachen Sportdirektor. Doch ich muss gestehen, er hat mich und viele andere eines Besseren belehrt, weil gerade seine ganze Erfahrung, die er gesammelt hat, als Scout auf vielen Stationen, auch international. Er hat in Aachen mal die zweite Mannschaft trainiert. Er hat dort mal das Nachwuchsleistungszentrum trainiert. Er war dann Scout, er war dann Sportdirektor in Aachen. Er hat die Perspektive eines Profifußballvereins aus ganz vielen Ecken kennengelernt. Ich glaube, das macht ihn auch gerade so stark und auch so beliebt. Auch in der Geschäftsstelle, die Stimmung, die auch innerhalb dieses Clubs herrscht, ist überhaupt nicht zu vergleichen mit dem, was dort vor zwei, drei, vier Jahren abgelaufen ist. Er hat einen Aufsichtsrat, der jetzt mit ihm zusammenarbeitet und nicht gegen ihn arbeitet und auch nicht sein eigenes Ding macht, was wir in Kaiserslautern immer wieder hatten über die Jahre, was ja das Grundproblem war. Dieses Miteinander, alle ziehen an einem Strang, und das vor allem, alle ziehen nach außen an einem Strang. Natürlich wird intern auch mal kontroverser diskutiert, aber es bleibt halt eben intern und nicht mehr wie früher. Ich will gar nicht sagen, dass es an die Presse gesteckt wird. Das wäre ja noch das Beste gewesen. Früher hat ja jeder über Facebook seine Visionen geteilt.
Das macht nur noch Hass an Ismail bei 1860, aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Und welche Rolle spielt dann Dirk Schuster in dem ganzen Gesamtgebilde Kaiserslautern?
Ich glaube, Dirk Schuster war gerade für diese beiden Relegationsspiele wirklich der perfekte Mann. Erfahrung ohne Ende, kennt Relegationsspiele und kann innerhalb eines kurzen Zeitraums was aus einer Mannschaft rausholen. Und wenn wir uns Dirk Schusters Mannschaften in der Vergangenheit angucken, haben sie ja in aller Regel überperformed. Darmstadt hat über die meiste Zeit überperformed. Auch Aue hat relativ sicher meistens den Klassenerhalt geschafft und ist danach ohne Dirk Schuster abgestiegen. Die Zeit in Augsburg klammert jetzt mal aus. Jetzt hat er in Kaiserslautern daran angeschlossen. Er hat für diese Mannschaft ein Konzept entwickelt, ein sportliches Konzept, das trotz beschränkter fußballerischer Qualitäten, die sie ohne die Neuzugänge hatte, funktioniert in dieser Liga mit einer relativ kompakten Defensive, vor allem mit einem schnellen Umschaltspiel, gerade über die Flügel. Er hat auch ein bisschen das Glück, dass die Chancenverwertung seiner Spieler relativ gut ist. Kaiserslautern ist beim Kicker unsere Chancenverwertungsstatistik auf Platz 2 hinter Heidenheim. 31, 6 Prozent aller Chancen landen tatsächlich im Tor. Deswegen funktioniert es spielerisch einfach. Dirk Schuster ist in der Mannschaft auch – es ist eine sehr gute Stimmung in der Mannschaft. Jeder schätzt Dirk auch in der Art und Weise, wie er mit Spielern umgeht. Er ist sehr ehrlich, er ist sehr gradlinig. Ich finde, in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung wird Dirk Schuster häufig unterschätzt. Er wird in diese Kategorie vielleicht alter Haudegen, alte Schule eingeordnet. Aber damit liegt man gar nicht richtig, sondern er ist super akribisch. Auch Dirk arbeitet super modern, was nicht nur Gegneranalyse angeht, auch was Ernährung angeht, was solche Komponenten – alles rund ums Training, wo du quasi alles, was du noch verbessern kannst, außerhalb des Platzes. Und das führt beim FCK aktuell zu einem guten Gesamtkonzept.
Aber wird es der Durchmarsch, den wir ja auch schon von Dirk Schuster gesehen haben? Ich habe mich unterhalten mit Lauternfans noch vor dieser Niederlagenserie, also diese kleine Niederlagenserie, die es jetzt gab. Die hatten davor fast Angst.
Hätten wir vor vier Wochen darüber gesprochen, hätte ich gesagt, ich halte das tatsächlich für möglich. Es waren alle Anzeichen, die damals auch in Darmstadt bei ihm darauf gezielt haben. Ganz lustig, die Hinrundenbilanz des FCK und Darmstadt in dem Jahr war total identisch, was Punkte, was Siege, was Unentschieden und was Niederlagen angeht. Aber die Mannschaft ist so ein bisschen aus dem Flow gekommen in den letzten Wochen. Diese drei Niederlagen waren nicht alle nötig. Zum Teil sind sie auch ein bisschen selbstverschuldet. Zum Teil hat auch Dirk Schuster seine Aktien daran. Er hat jetzt zuletzt viermal hintereinander die Grundformation gewechselt, von Dreierkette, Viererkette, Dreierkette, Viererkette. Das hat er in der Hinrunde alles gar nicht gemacht. Er hat sich zu oft zuletzt meiner Meinung nach dem Gegner so ein bisschen unterworfen. Ich weiß nicht, Olli, du kannst gerade vielleicht was dazu sagen, weil du hast Magdeburg gegen den FCK jetzt gesehen. Ich fand, der FCK hat überhaupt kein eigenes Spiel auf diesen Platz bringen wollen, sondern er hat gesagt, wir unterwerfen uns Magdeburg. Wir wollen mit einer Dreierkette spielen, damit diese spielstarke Offensive von Magdeburg nicht so zum Tragen kommt. Er hat aber gleichzeitig die offensiv schnellen Flügelspieler auf der Bank gelassen. Für mich hatte das Ganze nicht so Hand und Fuß.
Na gut, das kann vielleicht aus der Erfahrung heraus sein, weil relativ viele Mannschaften in dieser Saison Magdeburg das Spiel überlassen haben. Was jetzt für einen Aufsteiger vielleicht auch überraschend ist, aber das werden wir gleich noch besprechen. Die dann damit Erfolg hatten, dass sie Magdeburg haben spielen lassen. 50-60 Prozent teilweise Ballbesitz. Die dann aber oft einfache Fehler im Aufbauspiel gemacht haben, die man dann im Umschaltspiel oder mit Standards nutzen konnte, um zu Toren zu kommen. Vielleicht war das die Hoffnung von Dirk Schuster, die dann aber in dem Fall nicht aufgegangen ist.
Aber was ich da jetzt gerade noch betonen will, bei aller Kritik, die ich jetzt in den letzten Wochen auch bei uns im Kicker so ein bisschen an Dirk Schuster geäußert habe, ohne Dirk Schuster würde der FCK nicht da stehen, wo er steht. Der hat diesem Verein in dieser Saison wirklich ganz viele Punkte gesichert mit seiner Herangehensweise und wird auch noch einige Punkte holen.
Ja, das ist ja die gute Nachricht, dass quasi Lautern sich als erstes Team der Aufsteiger wahrscheinlich keine Sorgen mehr um einen Abstieg machen muss und das allein ist ja schon ein riesiger Erfolg. Alles andere dann ein großer Bonus. Aber wenn wir dann schon gerade bei Magdeburg sind und Olli, du ja auch schon hier so ein bisschen eine kleine Einführung gemacht hast, also allein die Ballbesitzzahlen sind doch sehr unterschiedlich zwischen Magdeburg und Lautern. Also bei Lautern haben wir häufig weniger Ballbesitz als der Gegner und bei Magdeburg ist es das krasse Gegenteil. Jetzt vielleicht mal ausgehend vom Lauternspiel. Man konnte zuletzt zweimal in Folge gewinnen gegen Hannover, gegen Lautern. Insgesamt hat man quasi die umgedrehte Lauternbilanz, nämlich drei Siege aus den letzten vier Spielen. Die braucht man auch. Wie spielt denn Magdeburg und stehen Sie damit auch auf einem Tabellenplatz? Wie gehört es sich deiner Meinung nach?
Als du vorhin darüber gesprochen hast und gesagt hast, es ist jetzt vielleicht ein schlechter Zeitpunkt für diesen Podcast, muss ich sagen, aus Magdeburg ist das bestimmt ein sehr guter Zeitpunkt, weil aus meiner Sicht steht der FCM so gut da wie noch nie in dieser Saison. Ich weiß, dass sie tabellarisch schon mal höher standen, aber ich glaube, der Abstand nach unten mit sechs Punkten war noch nie so groß. Deswegen aus Magdeburgers Sicht ist es ein sehr guter Moment, diesen Podcast jetzt zu machen. Der FCM ist in die Saison gegangen und wollte im Prinzip genauso weiter spielen wie in der dritten Liga, nämlich mit viel Ballbesitz, um dann die schnellen Spieler vorne oder die auch technisch versierten Spieler vorne und insbesondere Baris Atik in Szene zu setzen und zu Toren zu kommen. Das hat nicht so gut geklappt. Da haben Verletzungen eine Rolle gespielt. Baris Atik selber war auch zu Beginn der Saison verletzt, dann wahrscheinlich auch lange angeschlagen, auch wenn sie das nicht so in dem Maß erzählt haben. Sie war natürlich überrascht von der Körperlichkeit in der zweiten Liga. Das hat sich im Offensivspiel geäußert, weil sie da eben nicht so durchgekommen sind, wie das noch in der dritten Liga geklappt hat. Das hat sich defensiv da geäußert, dass sie dann einfach wahnsinnig viele Gegentore – ich habe es schon angesprochen – nach Umschaltsituationen oder nach Fehlern im Aufbauspiel und eben nach Standards bekommen haben. Dann gab es auch so einen Knall vor ein paar Wochen beim Spiel gegen den KSC. Da hat der FCM in der Nachspielzeit noch den Ausgleich gemacht. Die Spieler waren eigentlich super happy. Dann gab es eine Ansprache vom Vorsänger, die mit den Worten begann. Jungs, was ihr heute hier gezeigt habt, war eine absolute Frechheit. Dann wollte er das so ein bisschen ausführen. Dann ist Christian Tietz hin und wollte seine Spieler wegholen. Dann gab es natürlich ein bisschen Aufregung. In den nächsten Tagen war man sehr bemüht, das wieder zu glätten. Aber jetzt sieht es so aus, als ob das ein bisschen das Momentum war oder die Situation, die tatsächlich dazu geführt hat, dass der FCM spät in dieser Saison endlich in der 2. Liga angekommen ist. Weil sie es seitdem besser hinbekommen zu verteidigen, lassen sie immer noch relativ viel zu. Gegen Kaiserslautern war es jetzt nicht so viel. Aber wenn ich da auch noch an das Spiel gegen Kaiserslautern denke und insbesondere an das gegen Holstein Kiel, da hätte Kiel ja auch schon 4-5-0 führen müssen. Irgendwie ist der FCM trotzdem im Spiel geblieben und hat es dann am Ende gewonnen. Und dann hast du eben den Baris Atek, der letzte Saison, ich glaube, an die 40 Torbeteiligungen hatte, der jetzt wieder richtig gut in Form kommt, der in den letzten Spielen immer an einem Tor mindestens beteiligt war, teilweise auch an mehreren. Und dass sie es jetzt endlich irgendwie verstanden haben, eine Balance hinzubekommen, eben nicht mehr ganz so anfällig zu sein, nicht mehr ganz so riskant zu eröffnen und dann aber auch es schaffen, den Gegner nicht besser anzulaufen oder die Bälle besser zu gewinnen und sich einfach wieder schneller durchzuspielen, um dann eben zu mehr Chancen zu kommen und dadurch auch zu mehr Toren. Das war dann, glaube ich, so die Konstellation, auf die der FCK getroffen ist, eben so der FCM mit Rückenwind. Auch mit dem großen Wunsch, endlich mal wieder zu Hause zu gewinnen. Das sah ja bis jetzt in dieser Saison auch oft nicht gut aus. Und dann haben sie das relativ erfolgreich gemacht, ihre Linie da durchgezogen. Und dann haben wir auch völlig verdient gewonnen, aus meiner Sicht.
Und wie würdest du das bewerten, dass es so eine Ansprache braucht, die ja auch durchaus national ein bisschen belächelt wurde, so wie es ich gesehen habe, weil es ja auch untypisch ist, dass quasi so ein Team so in die Kanare genommen wird von einem Fan. Du bist ja viel näher dran als wir alle anderen. Wie würdest du das einordnen?
Na ja, in dem Moment, als das passiert ist, hatte ich so zwei Gefühle. Also erstmal muss man wissen, in Magdeburg ist das nicht unüblich. Da ist das eigentlich nach jedem Spiel. Die Spieler gehen vor die Fan-Kurve, dann gibt es ein paar Worte vom Vorsänger und dann wird irgendwie nochmal zusammengeklatscht und irgendwas gerufen. Ist auch, wenn sie gewonnen haben, ein bisschen lauter. Wenn sie verloren haben, ein bisschen leiser. Aber das ist eigentlich so das Ritual, dass man sich da nochmal gemeinsam verabschiedet. Und dann geht es eben in die Kabine. Deswegen war das jetzt nicht so ganz ungewöhnlich. Ja, die Wortwahl fand ich jetzt schon nicht ganz angemessen, aber jetzt auch noch nicht so, dass jemand direkt angegriffen wurde, aus meiner Sicht. Und habe in dem Moment mich gefragt, ob so eine Ansprache oder eine derartige Aktion – da gab es ja auch noch deutlich krassere Aktionen in der Vergangenheit. Weiß nicht, bei Eintracht Frankfurt oder bei Hansa Rostock oder so kann ich mich da auch erinnern, dass die Spieler da noch ganz anders angegangen wurden. Konnte ich mich jetzt nicht erinnern, dass das schon mal irgendwie was bewirkt hat. Und das habe ich dann in den Tagen danach auch so gesagt, diese Wahrnehmung. Aber es hat offenbar funktioniert. Und vielleicht selbst, wenn die Ansprache selbst das nicht war, sondern eher der Versuch, dann wieder zusammen zu rücken danach, dass das was bewirkt hat. Und das ist sicherlich nur ein Teilaspekt. Verletzungen habe ich angesprochen, dass jetzt ein paar Spieler einfach endlich mal ein paar Spiele in Reihe bekommen haben. Dass man nicht jedes Mal die Viererkette oder die Dreierkette oder wie auch immer das Mittelfeld umstellen muss. Das trägt mit Sicherheit auch dazu bei. Und ich glaube eben auch, dass ein paar Spieler, da waren auch viele Spieler dabei, die einfach noch nie 2. Bundesliga gespielt haben, dass die wirklich ein bisschen gebraucht haben, um auf dieses Niveau zu kommen, was sie jetzt aber offenbar geschafft haben. Und ja, diese Ansprache war der Auslöser, aber ich glaube, sie ist jetzt nicht der alleinige Grund, dass der FCM plötzlich von Sieg zu Sieg eilt.
Und wirft das deiner Meinung nach auch ein Licht auf Christian Titz, den Trainer, oder ist das dann quasi überinterpretiert? Weil eigentlich müsste ja von ihm so eine Botschaft kommen. Und allein die Tabellenkonstellation hat ja eigentlich auch gezeigt, wie eng die Lage ist. Das ist zwar alles sehr eng miteinander, aber du hast es ja schon gesagt, Magdeburg hatte 27 Punkte. Das sind gerade 6 Punkte Vorsprung auf den Relegationsplatz. Besser stand man in dieser Kategorie noch nicht da. Bisher war quasi Relegationsplatz um Magdeburg. Das ging Hand in Hand eigentlich so ein bisschen, dass man da immer sehr, sehr nah mit dran war. Also eigentlich hätte das ja schon allen klar sein müssen.
Ja, ich denke, das war auch allen klar. Ich habe auch sehr lange in dieser Saison gedacht, dass der Christian Tietz eben doch sehr stur war. Und ich habe das jetzt damals nicht verfolgt, als er in Essen oder beim HSV rausgeflogen ist. Ich habe dann bloß immer mal so einzelne Zeitungsschlagzeiten oder sowas von der Zeit damals gesehen, die auch so ein bisschen darauf hinde deuteten, dass er eben unbedingt an seiner Spielweise festhalten wollte, auch wenn die in dem Moment vielleicht nicht die passende war. Und jetzt muss man sagen, hat er recht behalten, weil er eben seiner Linie treu geblieben ist. Und hat es jetzt gerade diese Woche auch in einem Zeitungsinterview gesagt, dass er eben, genau was ich gerade angesprochen hatte, bestimmte Dinge Zeit brauchten. Und ich glaube, das ist für einen Fan immer, für mich jetzt ehrlicherweise auch, relativ schwer greifbar, wie viel Zeit sowas braucht. Dass das eben nicht mit 4, 5 Spielen getan ist, sondern dass das durchaus auch mal eine Halbserie dauern kann. Aber ja, er hat sich ja dann auch nach dieser Situation da in der Fan-Kurve hat er sich auch entschuldigt. So, und dann haben sie, wie gesagt, da schon alle Offiziellen, da irgendwie versucht, die Wogen zu glätten und die Fans wirklich auch wieder mit ins Boot zu nehmen. Das ging von ihm auch mit aus. In dem Moment fand er seine Mannschaft ungerecht behandelt, weil er eben sagte, sie haben gekämpft. Und wir haben dann auch nochmal nachgefragt auf der Pressekonferenz, wie er denn kämpfen ist. Das ist ja auch nur so ein Parameter, den man jetzt nicht direkt mit Zahlen beschreiben kann. Und dann hat er so ein paar Sachen gesagt, woran er festmacht, dass die Mannschaft gekämpft hat. Das war aus meiner Sicht plausibel. Dass man das im Stadion teilweise nicht so wahrnimmt, kann ich aus einer Fansicht auch verstehen. Aber da hat man irgendwie wieder zusammengefunden. Und wie gesagt, da hat er jetzt ein paar kleine Dinge angepasst. Aber ein paar Dinge haben sich auch einfach gefügt. Und ich habe es gesagt, Stand jetzt hat er dann doch recht behalten. Auch wenn wir uns da vor ein paar Wochen schon alle gefragt haben, ob dieser Weg tatsächlich der richtige ist.
Da würde ich gerne gleich nochmal ausführlicher drüber reden. Aber an der Stelle würde ich Anna gerne nochmal mit einschalten. Denn wenn wir jetzt eine Tabelle bilden würden, dieser drei Teams untereinander, dann läge ja Eintracht Braunschweig vorne. Denn man hat nicht verloren, weder gegen Kaiserslautern noch gegen Magdeburg. Was sagt das über Braunschweig und was sagt das über die Gegner? Oder war das zum jeweiligen Zeitpunkt dann ein guter Moment, gegen die zu spielen?
Ja, ich glaube tatsächlich, also die beiden Spiele stehen ja jetzt auch noch aus in der Rückrunde. Das heißt, ich glaube, habt ihr schon zweimal gegeneinander gespielt? Weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Genau, gerade jetzt zuletzt.
Ja, genau, deswegen steht das Ergebnis ja noch aus. Ja, wir hatten diese gute Phase im Herbst, die ich sehr vermisse. Ich fürchte, ich muss es eher mit Form erklären, denn mit Qualität oder tatsächlich irgendwie bewusster Herführung. Ja, sprechen wir ja sicherlich auch gleich noch drüber. Unser Auftaktprogramm war in der Hinrunde, logischerweise auch in der Rückrunde, sehr taff, sehr bitter. Und nachdem wir uns da dann so ein bisschen gefangen hatten, lief es sehr gut. Und nachdem die Mannschaft eingespielt war, in den Wochen, in denen alle fit gewesen sind, inklusive Emanuel Feray, waren wir zu Recht schwer zu schlagen. Mal gucken, wie dann die Rückspiele ausgehen.
Mal schauen, ob wir da dann in der Vergangenheitsform die ganze Zeit bleiben werden oder ob das nochmal zurückkommt. Aber gut, zu Braunschweig kommen wir ja gleich nochmal ausführlicher. Oliver, wenn du jetzt mal so auf die Gesamtsituation guckst. Wir haben sie jetzt schon tabellarisch eingeordnet. Das sieht alles ganz gut aus. Du hast uns jetzt schon erklärt, welche Dynamik diese Saison hatte. Wir haben auch schon über den besonderen spielerischen Ansatz von Magdeburg gesprochen. Wie optimistisch bist du denn, dass man das auch schaffen kann, sich in der Liga zu halten?
Stand jetzt recht optimistisch, weil es tatsächlich deutlich besser aussieht als noch vor ein paar Wochen. Und es war eben nicht so, dass man sagen kann, Hinrunde war in der Summe nicht so gut, Rückrunde war total gut. Es waren ja auch in der Rückrunde noch drei, vier Spiele dabei, die genauso gelaufen sind von den Ergebnissen und auch von der Spielweise her wie in der Hinrunde. Deswegen wir dann eben schon alle irgendwo Zweifel hatten, ob das was werden kann. Jetzt kann ich mich noch erinnern, der Kommentar bei Sky am Wochenende beim Spiel, da hieß es irgendwie Magdeburg hat aus sechs Spielen zwei gewonnen. Jetzt du hast es auch gesagt, ist die Formulierung plötzlich aus den letzten Vieren haben sie drei gewonnen. Da sieht man ja schon die ganz andere Herangehensweise. Wenn ich jetzt gucke, gegen Nürnberg spielen sie noch, gegen Hansa Rostock, die ja momentan auch wirklich nicht gut drauf sind, spielen sie noch, gegen Braunschweig spielen sie noch, gegen Bielefeld spielen sie noch. Sie haben alle Mannschaften von unten noch. Sie haben die Mittelfeldmannschaften oder die gesicherten Mannschaften. Die haben sie überwiegend weg. Deswegen bin ich in der aktuellen Form tatsächlich sehr optimistisch, dass das was werden kann mit dem Klassenhalt für den 1. FC Magdeburg.
Und wie sehr hängt das dann tatsächlich am spielerbarisch Artik? Weil du hast ihn jetzt selber schon öfter ins Spiel gebracht. Wir haben auch, wenn wir hier über Magdeburg gesprochen haben, viel dieser Name bisher auch immer im Rasenfunk. Und die Frage, die ich mir da schon das letzte Mal, als ich das moderiert habe, gestellt habe, wie kann das eigentlich sein, dass ein Team so von einem Spieler abhängt und dass das dann auch die Gegner nicht schaffen, denjenigen aus dem Spiel zu nehmen? Ist das vielleicht auch einfach nur ein falscher Eindruck von mir? Also gibt es noch andere wichtige Spieler? Oder ist es tatsächlich so, dass er die Erklärung für auch die Erfolgswelle dann ist?
Für die aktuelle Erfolgswelle würde ich definitiv sagen, die kann man an ihm festmachen, weil die einfach mit seiner aufsteigenden Form auch zusammenhängt und eben mit seinen Torbeteiligungen. Du hast natürlich auch noch andere Spieler. Moritz Quateng hat auch schon acht Tore diese Saison gemacht, ist wirklich auch gefährlich. Tatsua Ito, den letzten Wochen auch stark gewesen, einige Torbeteiligungen gehabt. Und es sind aber tatsächlich aus meiner Sicht die Offensivspieler, die rausragen. Sie haben jetzt im Winter zum Beispiel noch Daniel Heber von Rot-Weiß Essen geholt. Das, finde ich, ist mittlerweile eine Verstärkung für die Abwehr. Bringt da eine gewisse Stabilität rein, auch wenn er gleich im ersten Spiel gegen Düsseldorf böse gepatzt hat. Aber seitdem auch wieder ein Spieler, der noch nie 2. Bundesliga gespielt hatte, hat er sich da gut reingearbeitet. Und ich glaube, die Qualität des FCM ist aber tatsächlich das Offensivspiel. Und das kann man dann schon an barischer Artik auch festmachen. Und ja, wenn er in dem Maß weiter trifft und vorbereitet, wie er das aktuell macht, dann wird der FCM den Klassenhalt schaffen. Aber ja, um auf die Frage nochmal so einzugehen, ich glaube schon, dass das in einem großen Maß an ihm hängt.
Verrückt. Aber ist ja auch schön, wenn das so funktioniert. Und wann kommt die Heimstärke wieder?
Letzte Woche.
Okay, gut. Also ab jetzt wird die Serie gestartet. War das der Beginn der Serie?
Das werden wir sehen, aber warum nicht?
Ordne mir mal noch kurz ein in ein paar Sätzen, wie die Situation jetzt generell in Magdeburg ist. Also beim Verein. Was würde es denn jetzt bedeuten, sollte es wieder in die dritte Liga runtergehen? Weil das letzte Mal, als wir über Magdeburg gesprochen haben, haben wir auch viel über so eben Umfeld und wirtschaftliche Situation und so weiter gesprochen. Hat sich da was verbessert? Ist man stabiler geworden? Was würde es bedeuten, wenn jetzt man im schlechtesten Fall eben dann doch wieder absteigen würde?
Ich glaube, dann würde sich gar nicht so viel ändern. In Magdeburg ist man ja auch dazu übergegangen, nicht mehr zu kommunizieren, wie lange Verträge jetzt eigentlich laufen. Man hat im Winter den Vertrag mit dem Trainer trotz der tabellarischen Situation verlängert. Er hat aber nicht gesagt, bis wann und auch nicht, ob der Vertrag für die 3. Liga auch gilt. Aber ich vermute, wenn sie das ohne Not so kommunizieren, dass man auch mit Christian Tietz wieder in die 3. Liga gehen würde. Ich denke, da könnte man auch wieder eine gute Rolle spielen. Ob man da jetzt sofort wieder aufsteigt, kann ich dir nicht sagen. Im Umfeld passiert ein bisschen was. Da wird an den Trainingsplätzen und an der Struktur gearbeitet. Man versucht sich da breiter aufzustellen. Aber man hat auch immer noch diese Maxime, dass man sagt, klar, in der 3. Liga sind die Mittel irgendwo begrenzt. Das heißt, wenn man mal 2, 3 Jahre 2. Liga spielen würde, die Pläne sind so weit in der Schublade oder teilweise auch in Arbeit. Aber dann würde man die rausführen und sagen, okay, jetzt können wir das machen, jetzt können wir das machen. Das passiert so Schritt bei Schritt. Aber ich glaube auch aufgrund der Zuschauerzahlen, die natürlich für die 3. Liga an Spitzenwert sind – in der 2. Liga ist man da einer von vielen – könnte man da sicherlich wieder eine gute Rolle spielen und würde wahrscheinlich nicht ganz so abstürzen, wie es nach dem ersten Abstieg aus der 2. Bundesliga passiert ist.
Ja, der Abstieg in die 3. Liga ist eben auch einfach ein harter, aber kein Abstieg ist einfach. Aber gut, ich will es ja gar nicht heraufbespüren. Ich habe mir eben nur diese Frage gestellt, weil ich mich so ein bisschen zurückerinnert habe an die erste Sendung, die wir zwar aufgenommen haben. Dahingehend hat sich ja wirklich viel, viel, viel bei Magdeburg getan. Und ähnlich ist es bei Eintracht Braunschweig, auch wenn ich mit Anna da noch nicht drüber gesprochen habe. Anna, wenn ich mir jetzt die Eintracht anschaue, dann liegt die auf Platz 15 aktuell. Also einen Punkt vor dem Relegationsplatz. Man ist mittendrin unten, aber man hat es auch wieder ein bisschen geschafft. Du hast es schon vorhin angesprochen. Es gab diesen goldenen Herbst, möchte ich immer nennen, und dann sehr lange wenig. Aber jetzt ja zum Beispiel ein 3 zu 3 gegen Aminia Bielefeld, einen direkten Abstiegskonkurrenten, bei dem man schon sehr deutlich, überdeutlich, fast schon hätte man meinen können, zurückgelegen ist. Ist das jetzt die Einleitung des goldenen Frühlings, dieses 3 zu 3?
Hoffentlich. Also der Ex-Bielefeld-Trainer, kann man ja sagen, hat das Spiel ja zum wichtigsten Spiel der Saison ausgerufen im Vorhinein. Ob das jetzt nur für Aminia Bielefeld gilt oder auch für Eintracht Braunschweig sei dahingestellt, das kann ich dann irgendwie im Mai bewerten. Ja, hoffentlich. Hoffentlich tatsächlich. Also ich versuche so ein bisschen die Fahne des Optimismus oben zu halten, im Umfeld, im Freundeskreis und auf Twitter, nämlich immer wieder sage ich ja, aber wir haben jetzt mehr Punkte als in der Hinrunde zu diesem Zeitpunkt. Ich fürchte, dass wir sind…
Aber da war es auch nur, da war es nur einer, oder?
Da war es einer, jetzt sind es vier. Ja, weil wir ja gegen Heidenheim gewonnen haben, coolerweise. Und deswegen ist es nicht schlechter als in der Hinrunde, auch wenn es sich irgendwie ein bisschen so anfühlt, weil wir natürlich nicht mit einem Aufstieg in diese Durststrecke gestartet sind, sondern dann doch mit erheblich wenig Siegen im Winter sind jetzt lange ohne Sieg. der Sieg gegen Heidenheim am Anfang Februar, am 4.02. Und davor haben wir das letzte Mal Mitte Oktober tatsächlich gegen Magdeburg gewonnen, auswärts 2 zu 0. Und danach verließen sie uns irgendwie. Hatten extrem viel Verletzungspech. Du hattest eben gerade die Konzentration auf einen einzigen Spieler angesprochen. Ich fürchte, die ereilt uns tatsächlich auch, weil wir einfach angewiesen sind auf Fitness und Laune von unserer Nummer 10. Das ist Emanuel Feray, der kam letzten Sommer von Borussia Dortmund 2. Und alle sind sich sehr sicher, dass der im Sommer hoffentlich für eine relevante Summe den Verein wieder verlassen wird. Ich habe zumindest nichts anderes gehört. Nimmt ihm auch keiner besonders übel, der will sich gerne zeigen, die Vermutung, und dann eben im Sommer nach oben wechseln. Der war lange verletzt. Und das hat man gemerkt auf unterschiedlichen Ebenen tatsächlich, sowohl sportlich als auch – das finde ich einen ganz interessanten Faktor – irgendwie auch in dem Team. Der Trainer hat, sobald es möglich war, immer versucht, ihn einzuwechseln. Und die Mannschaft hat, sobald er auf dem Platz stand, einen anderen Eindruck gemacht, weil sie plötzlich irgendwie Hoffnung hatte oder Mut oder beides. Und ohne ihn, wenn der jetzt langfristig ausfällt, sehe ich leider ziemlich schwarz. Würde ich schwarz sehen, weil er ist ja gesund.
Er ist ja gesund, wir wünschen ihm natürlich auch gesundheitlich nur das Beste. Aber ein bisschen wundert mich ja, dass jetzt der Name Anthony Uther noch gar nicht gefallen ist. Der war doch zwischendurch auch so der Hoffnungsbringer und war da nicht auch wesentlicher Teil? Also Ferei ja sowieso, aber auch Uther war doch Teil dieses goldenen Herbstes.
Ja, also sie haben tatsächlich gleich viele Tore geschossen. Ferei hat mehr Vorlagen, ist eben auch positioninherent wahrscheinlich. Ich habe trotzdem den Eindruck, dass das, was das Team beweglich macht und nach vorne zieht und vor allem unberechenbar macht, also wer Lust hat, der möge sich, dass den 2 zu 3 Anschlusstreffer vom letzten Wochenende gegen Aminia Bielefeld Ferei im Zusammenspiel mit Maurice Muldtaub anschauen. Das ist einfach wirklich ein toller Fußballer. Das haben wir in Braunschweig relativ lange nicht gehabt. Auch Anthony Uccia, ich muss an dieser Stelle gerne ein wenig Abbildte leisten, weil ich über diesen Transfer im Sommer ein wenig die Augen gerollt habe, weil ich so dachte, der hat irgendwie was am Knie. So ein älterer Spieler, der was am Knie hat. Das ist doch naja gut, warum nicht? Und dann tatsächlich er so das erste Auftrumpfen des Potenzials, das in dem Duo Ferai Uccia stecken könnte, war tatsächlich beim Derby, auswärts in Hannover. Wenn die beide fit sind und beide Bock haben, dann macht das extrem viel Spaß, definitiv.
Und wie ist so der Fußball von Eintracht Braunschweig? Wie muss ich mir den vorstellen? Also ich weiß, als wir das letzte Mal hier im Rasenfunk drüber gesprochen haben, da hat einer der Gäste aufgezählt, dass Braunschweig den geringsten Ballbesitz der Liga hat. Bei der Laufleistung liegt man sehr weit hinten, dafür bei den Sprints sehr weit vorne. Also wenn, dann wird quasi im hohen Tempo gelaufen, sage ich jetzt mal. Was ist denn für ein Fußball? Jetzt auch vielleicht im Unterschied zu Lautern und Magdeburg, über die wir ja schon gesprochen haben.
Es kommt drauf an, würde ich sagen, ob du über die ersten 20… Ja, ob du die ersten 20 Minuten oder die 72 meinst. Also grundsätzlich wenig Ballbesitz. Je nach dem versuchen wir den Gegner zu beschäftigen, indem wir vorne interessanter sind, als man das für einen Aufsteiger vermuten wollen würde. Hinten stehen wir mit einer Dreierkette aus drei Innenverteidigern. Auch hier verletzungsgeplagt leider. Davor natürlicherweise die Außenverteidiger Anton Donkor. Er ist da, treibende Kraft auf der linken Seite, wirklich mit krassem Tempo, ein unfassbar schneller Außenbahnspieler. Leider defensiv mit deutlichen Schwächen, was jetzt für einen Außenverteidiger vielleicht nicht unbedingt werbend ist. Nach vorne aber durchaus spannend reißt er die Lücken auf. Diese Umschaltmomente sind, glaube ich, das, was uns am Leben halten, wenn sie funktionieren, weil wir hinten den Ball sichern, um dann nach vorne zu spielen über Außen, den dann relativ zeitig in die Mitte spielen, Richtung Zehn, um dann durch die Mitte zu kombinieren. Flanken, Standard-Situationen, sowohl aktiv als auch passiv, sind nicht unsere besten Freunde.
Das macht euch durchaus sympathisch, zumindest in meinen Augen. Aber wie hast du das mit den 20 Minuten gemeint? Ich glaube ja nicht ganz so positiv, wenn ich mir einfach nur so die Gegentorverteilung angucke. Da hat man allein in der ersten Viertelstunde schon sieben Gegentreffer kassiert. Nur Regensburg und der HSV sind da noch schlechter. Also die zweiten 70 Minuten sind die besseren Minuten, ja?
Definitiv, ja. Definitiv. Also das, was gemacht wird in der ersten Viertelstunde, ich kann es nicht so richtig beschreiben. Es wird auch schlimmer. Es klingt, als würde ich über eine Krankheit reden. Es hat auch ein bisschen was davon. Ist natürlich auch dem geschuldet, dass wir unglaublich häufig umstellen müssen aufgrund von Verletzungen. Die Innenverteidigung stand. Das waren hervorragend. Auch gute Transfers, die sofort funktioniert haben. Priam Behrend, der aus Bielefeld gekommen ist. Philipp Benkovic. Ich habe gerade über Standards gesprochen. Seitdem der weg ist, funktioniert das mit offensiven Standards nicht mehr besonders gut. Aber auch in der Defensive fehlt er uns natürlich. Dann haben wir Saulo de Carli in der Innenverteidigung, der aus Bochum kam. Tolle Fußballer, die aber größtenteils verletzt sind. Den Trainer dazu zwingen, diese Dreierkette immer wieder umzustellen, was zu furchtbaren Abstimmungsproblemen zwischen Defensive und Torwart führt. Jasmin Fezic ist alt, groß. Das eine ist ein Nachteil, das andere ist ein Vorteil. Auf der Position zum Mal. Dessen Zeit läuft dann doch allmählich ab. Der ist jetzt 36 Jahre alt. Meiner Meinung nach sollte da jemand anders einmählich Einzug halten, spätestens im Sommer. Das tritt aus irgendwelchen Gründen in den ersten 20 Minuten sehr, sehr krass zutage. Dann beweist die Mannschaft etwas, was die Fanszene nicht mehr hören kann, nämlich wirklich unfassbare Moral. Und kämpft sich da eben zurück. Du liegst zu Hause mit Abstiegskandidaten 3-0 zurück und kannst dann fast noch 4-3 gewinnen. Das ist schon cool. Das ist, glaube ich, auch nicht selbstverständlich, auch gerade nicht in der Situation. Und das, was mir wesentlich Hoffnung gibt, weil so krass ist die sportliche Qualität des Kaders nicht. Aber sie glaubt an sich und das ist spürbar und gut zu sehen.
Welche Rolle spielt der Trainer Michael Schiele? Denen kennen vielleicht die Hörerinnen und Hörer noch. Der war ganz lange bei den Würzburger Kickers. Wer sich an seine Sandhauserzeit erinnert, da ziehe ich dann meinen Hut. Der war hier im Rasenfunk damals auch behandelt, aber die Sandhauserzeit war nur 14 Spiele lang. Und dann eben seit Juni 2021 bei Eintracht Braunschweig. Was ist er für einen Trainer und was lässt er für einen Fußballspiel?
Ja, zum einen… Oder ich glaube… Ich glaube, du kannst wahrscheinlich immer noch nicht in Braunschweig über Trainer reden, ohne über Thorsten Levergen nicht zu sprechen.
Wobei, andererseits, wenn ich mir die Tabelle so angucke, kann ich das auch verstehen.
Es ist, weißt du, diese eine große Liebe. Und vielleicht funktioniert es mit Michael Schiele so gut, weil er ein kleiner, dünner Mann aus Süddeutschland ist. Vielleicht geht Eintracht Braunschweig nur mit kleinen, dünnen Männern aus Süddeutschland. Könnte sein. Michael Schiele ist deswegen, also natürlich ist es ein bisschen lustig gemeint. Und ich glaube, typmäßig sind die beiden auch gar nicht so unterschiedlich. Aber das, wonach wir uns in Braunschweig nach diesem wirklich sehr tragischen Abstieg 2018 gesehen haben, bringt er einfach wieder so ein bisschen mit. Nämlich eine Mannschaft, bei der man die Spieler kennt und sich mit Typen identifizieren kann, mit denen er gut umgehen kann. Fabio Kaufmann beispielsweise, der glaube ich immer schlechte Laune hat. Aber das ist toll. Der ärgert sich darüber, dass die Mannschaft da steht, wo sie steht, weil er der Meinung ist, dass sie weiter oben stehen könnte, wenn Details anders funktionieren würden. Das ist natürlich aus der sehr großen Fanperspektive gesprochen, aber vor allem passt das irgendwie. Vom Typ her nach Fehlversuchen über Antwerpen beispielsweise. Naja, diese Ausflüge. Tatsächlich, ja, genau. Und er lässt halt tatsächlich Fußball spielen, und auch das ist in Braunschweig gar nicht so häufig gesehen. Und hatte sich in der 3. Liga so auch noch nicht angedeutet. Aber das, was der Herbst gezeigt hat, oder was auch punktuell immer wieder aufplutzt, auch von Anfang an gezeigt wurde bei dem ersten Spiel gegen den HSV letzten Sommer, dieses Pokalspiel gegen die Hertha, das wir gewonnen haben im Elfmeterschießen. Diese Mannschaft ist extrem dynamisch und er kriegt es gebacken über wirklich eine lange, lange, lange Kette der Verletzung, die maximale Flexibilität einzelner Spieler auszuschöpfen, so dass innerhalb kurzer Zeit sie sich anpassen können auf eine Position, auf der sie spielen müssen, weil sie da spielen müssen, weil Verletzungen sie eben dort hinbringen. Und ich bin immer wieder überrascht darüber, dass wir als Aufsteiger natürlicherweise nicht so viel Ballbesitz haben, aber wirklich phasenweise extrem schönen Kombinationsfußball nach vorne spielen. Wie gesagt, gar nicht so sehr über die Außen Richtung Grundlinie laufen, Richtung Eckfahne und dann irgendwie von weit rein flanken, sondern nach Möglichkeit eben den Weg durch die Mitte suchen, die Kombination in den Strafraum rein. Vielleicht ist es zu kompliziert für das, was die einzelnen Spieler können. Vielleicht sollte man versuchen, das schnörkelloser zu machen. Aber wenn es funktioniert, ist es wirklich erstaunlich unterhaltsam. Fußball macht nicht so oft Spaß als Fan.
Ja, das stimmt. Und vor allem ist Eintracht Braunschweig so ein Team, das lässt sich, glaube ich, schwer unterkriegen. Also nicht nur wegen dieses 3 zu 3s am Wochenende. Das war natürlich jetzt irgendwie paradigmatisch dafür. Aber das ist schon eine Qualität. Aber wenn ich mir jetzt mal die Bilanz von Eintracht Braunschweig angucke. Du hattest eben diesen traumatisierenden Abstieg damals 2018. In den letzten fünf Spielzeiten hat man dreimal dritte Liga gespielt und jetzt eben zweimal zweite Liga. Und es ging eben einmal hoch, dann gleich wieder runter. Und dann hat man es ja auch wieder geschafft, gleich wieder hoch zu gehen. Das ist ja das, worüber wir vorhin gesprochen haben. Der Aufstieg auf der Couch, der dann vielleicht nicht ganz so emotional war. Aber es ist ja trotzdem auch ein Aufstieg. Und es ist ja auch wichtig für einen ganzen Standort, für einen Bundesligastandort, dass man eben diese Zweitligagelder bekommt. Wie ist denn die Struktur bei der Eintracht gerade so aufgestellt? Ich meine, wir müssen jetzt ja nicht mit 66, 67 anfangen, auch wenn das natürlich die absolute Hochzeit war. Aber wo steht denn die Eintracht? Ist man jetzt so ein Pendel-Team zwischen zweiter und dritter Liga? Oder siehst du Anzeichen, dass man diesem Pendel-Modus vielleicht mal nach oben entgegen könnte?
Ja, das ist meine Hoffnung sowieso. Ich sage viel Hoffnung, aber was anderes bleibt irgendwie auch nicht.
Du musst glauben. Wenn ihr schon Spieler habt, die wie bei Tätlesso immer schlechte Laune haben, dann musst du auch jetzt ein Spieler werden.
Fabio Kaufmann wäre eine sehr gute Besetzung für Tätlesso auf jeden Fall. Wir hatten in Braunschweig diese wirklich guten Jahre. Gar nicht so sehr Bundesliga, das war ein schöner Ausflug. Aber es war einfach schön, daran zu denken, dass ein Wochenende Spieltag ist. Das strahlte auch so über den Verein hinweg. Das NLZ ist aufgebaut worden, etwas außerhalb des Stadtzentrums in so einer sehr schönen Parkgrünanlage. Die U19 hat den DFB-Pokal gegen Jena gewonnen. Plötzlich ist so ein Schlaglicht aufgetaucht auf diese sehr kleine Stadt mit diesem komischen Verein. Dem haben wir irgendwie nicht richtig standhalten können. Mit viel Pech meiner Meinung nach auch. Wir sind damals mit 67 Punkten in der Relegation gelandet. 1996 und Stuttgart sind aufgestiegen. Die Relegation haben wir dann gegen Wolfsburg verloren. Dann sind wir mit 39 Punkten direkt abgestiegen in die 3. Liga. Dann sind wir fast nochmal abgestiegen, klasse gehalten, nicht in die Regionalliga abgerutscht durch einen 1-1 gegen Cottbus am letzten Spieltag. Und davon musst du dich erst mal erholen. Deswegen nehme ich dieser Gesamtdynamik, eine gewisse Fahrstuhltendenz auch gar nicht übel. Ich glaube, das geht fast nicht anders, wenn du einmal wirklich so krass plötzlich dich in eine Krise wählst, die einfach unfair ist, weil du denkst, ich habe gar nichts gemacht. Ich habe wirklich nichts gemacht. Rein statistisch spiele ich gerade 2. Liga. Wie kann das sein? Dann, klar, Geschäftsstelle, das muss alles ausgedünnt werden. Du hattest es gesagt, 3. Liga ist schlimm finanziell. Ich fürchte, man kann an dieser Stelle nicht anders, oder ich kann zumindest nicht anders, als über die Vertragssituation vieler Spieler zu sprechen in Verbindung mit der Person, die diese Verträge ausgehandelt hat. Das ist Peter Vollmann, der Sportdirektor. Das ist das, was ich vorhin meinte, als ich in Bezug auf Kaiserslautern gesagt habe, dass ich da von außen zumindest den Eindruck habe, da wird so nach vorne geschaut. Selbst wenn man nicht mit der Bundesliga plant. Aber du hast so eine Idee von, wir bauen hier jetzt was auf. Und bei Peter Vollmann habe ich das Gefühl, der kann halt nur Druckverbände, aber diese Wunde müsste veratztet werden. Die Spieler sind geliehen, die gehen irgendwie im Sommer zurück. Fähre ist eine goldene Ausnahme. Wir hoffen, dass er eben Geld in die Kassen spürt, von dem wir hoffen, dass es sinnvoll investiert wird. Aber dass wir diesen Fahrstuhl verlassen, da bin ich diesbezüglich wirklich perspektivisch leider eher pessimistisch, weil mir einfach so gerne ich den Kader im Moment mag, weil mir die Typen gefallen und weil mir die Dynamik gefällt, ist sie aber langfristig nicht konservierbar, weil wir keinen Mannschaftskern haben, der vertraglich über mehrere Jahre an den Verein gebunden ist. Man übt sich da irgendwie in so einem Pragmatismus. Du gehst da eh hin, ob jetzt 2. oder 3. Liga. Ich glaube schon, dass wir die Chance haben, im Sommer die Klasse zu halten. Aber ob wir uns wirklich etablieren können, da würde ich im Moment leider ein großes Fragezeichen hinter machen.
Dann lasst man noch zu dritt gerne – oder zu viert, ich bin ja auch mit dabei, aber ihr sollt den Blick werfen, deswegen zu dritt – auf die Abstiegssituation generell blicken. Also ich mache jetzt mal den Cut bei Rang 11. Da kann man sich ja drüber streiten, aber ich mache es jetzt einfach mal so. Viert und Magdeburg haben 27 Punkte, der 1. FC Nürnberg 25, Hansa Rostock 24, Braunspark 22, Bielefeld 21, mit neuem Sportdirektor und neuem Trainer Uwe Koschinath, und Sandhausen dann 20 und Regensburg 20. Das heißt, alles sehr eng. Allein die letzten vier Plätze trennen allein 2 Punkte bzw. 3 Punkte. Olli, du darfst jetzt mal vorlegen. Wie blickst du auf diesen Abstiegskampf? Gibt es da Teams, wo du sagst, die müssten da eigentlich auf jeden Fall noch unten rauskommen und Magdeburg muss irgendwie versuchen, andere hinter sich zu lassen? Wer sind da für dich die entscheidenden Namen?
Ich würde gerne kurz noch was zu Anna antworten wollen. Zwei Gedanken, die ich dabei hatte, als es jetzt zu Michael Schiele ging. Erstmal finde ich es bemerkenswert, dass bei allen drei Aufsteigern die Trainer, die zur Saison beginnen, da waren, immer noch im Amtssinn. Das ist, glaube ich, nicht ganz selbstverständlich. Das ist, glaube ich, schon auch ein Qualitätsmerkmal dieser Mannschaften in dieser Saison. Und das Thema Verträge, das ist natürlich gerade in der dritten Liga üblich. Da wird an allen anderen Standorten auch immer eher rumgeweint, warum die Spieler nur ein oder zwei Jahre Verträge bekommen. Weil sie es oder ihre Berater es wollen. Weil sie alle davon ausgehen, dass sie eigentlich zu höheren Berufen sind und sich dann nicht ihre Zukunft verbauen wollen. Und das hat man bei Hansa letztes Jahr gesehen, als man dann plötzlich das erste Mal in der Lage war, eben nicht 14 Spieler im Sommer zu tauschen, sondern als man plötzlich gesagt hat, okay, wir behalten jetzt die meisten von denen, die wir haben und wollen tatsächlich mal so einen Kern formen, um eben aus diesem Fahrstuhl rauszukommen oder aus diesem jeden Sommer neuer Unbruch. Und das fand ich eigentlich ganz spannend, diese Herangehensweise. Und damit eben auch verbunden die Hoffnung, dass man tatsächlich es schafft mit einer Mannschaft, die bewiesen hat, dass sie den Klasse halt in der 2. Bundesliga schaffen kann, das im Kern wieder anzugehen. Und da sind wir direkt auch bei dem Team, in dem ich natürlich hoffe, dass sie sich da unten noch verabschieden oder dass sie sich, sagen wir, zumindest tabellarisch nicht verschlechtern, nämlich Hansa Rostock, was jetzt nicht mein Arbeitsteam ist, sondern dann mein Herzensverein. Und wo ich mir schon wünschen würde, dass wir nächste Saison dann auch mit einem Auswärtsspiel im DFB-Pokal starten dürfen. Das würde bedeuten, mindestens Platz 14. Und ja, aber da ist natürlich die Entwicklung sehr, sehr schlecht. Hansa Rostock hat jetzt in der Rückrunde erst ein Tor gemacht in Bielefeld. Das eine Tor hat immerhin zu einem Sieg gereicht, aber alle anderen Spiele zu null verloren. Da waren am Anfang jetzt klar HSV Heidenheim Darmstadt dabei. Dass man gegen die verliert, ist jetzt nicht komplett überraschend. Aber dass man zuletzt gegen den KSC quasi chancenlos war und auch beim FC St. Pauli nicht so sonderlich viel anzubieten hatte, das war schon besorgniserregend. Hansa hat den Trainer schon mal gewechselt. Jetzt habe ich das Gefühl, schon wieder überlegt, das noch mal zu machen. Wie erfolgsversprechend das ist, sieht man ja unter anderem in Nürnberg, nämlich nicht sehr. Und Sportdirektor Martin Piekenhagen steht da auch sehr in der Kritik. Also da ist momentan so eine Dynamik drin, wo ich mir ein bisschen Sorgen mache, muss ich sagen. In Nürnberg bin ich sehr gespannt jetzt mit Dieter Hecking, ob sie es da tatsächlich schaffen, da unten rauszukommen und auch seine Ankündigung, die jetzt zu lesen war, zu erfüllen. Nämlich, dass der Kader viel besser ist, als das der vorherige Trainer zum Beispiel eingeschätzt hat und wo der Sportdirektor Dieter Hecking gesagt hat, nee, der Kader ist viel besser und ich will jetzt auch zeigen, dass es tatsächlich so ist.
Es ist auch überraschend, dass der Trainer Dieter Hecking vom Sportdirektor Dieter Hecking zusammengestellten Kader sagt, der ist doch eigentlich prima.
Das ist klar, aber da entscheidet sich ja dann auch der Fortgang seiner Karriere mit dieser Aussage und mit dieser Konstellation. Bielefeld finde ich sehr spannend. Uwe Koschinert ist ein Trainer, den ich sehr mag, der jetzt auch schon lange in der dritten Liga gearbeitet hat, den ich deswegen immer im Blick hatte. Das ist ein Macher, würde ich sagen, und ein Typ, der in der Mannschaft mitreißen kann. Und vielleicht ist das der Faktor, was Amina Bielefeld jetzt braucht, um da unten rauszukommen. Ich wäre ehrlich gesagt nicht traurig, wenn Sandhausen und Regensburg sich in die dritte Liga verabschieden. Das ist jetzt auch so eine persönliche Präferenz, wo ich denke, in der zweiten Liga fallen sie vom ganzen Umfeld, von der Stimmung und so jetzt schon ein bisschen ab. Das sind jetzt keine Standorte, wo man denkt, wenn man gegen die spielt, boah krass, heute Regensburg oder so. Da freut man sich irgendwie auf einen netten Nachmittag. Sandhausen genauso.
Ja, aber was wird denn dann das neue Sandhausen? Weil immer, wenn jemand in der ersten Liga kurz vor dem Abstieg steht, dann heißt es ja, oh je, nächstes Jahr müssen sie nach Sandhausen fahren. Was würde denn dann das neue Sandhausen sein, frage ich dich?
Der SV Elbersberg, der aus der dritten Liga dabei ist.
Ein klarer Punkt für dich, hast du recht.
Ne, und Magdeburg habe ich gesagt, da denke ich, oder da bin ich recht optimistisch. Fürth hat sich da jetzt auch ein bisschen rausgearbeitet. Spannend finde ich Hannover 96. Da bin ich mir noch nicht ganz sicher, ob die nicht nochmal unten reinrutschen. Ich meine, die haben jetzt schon 30 Punkte, aber sie haben in der Rückrunde, wenn ich es richtig im Kopf habe, eben auch erst ein Unentschieden geholt. Und da ist die Stimmung, soweit ich das aus der Ferne betrachten kann, ja auch sehr, sehr negativ gerade. Da bin ich gespannt, ob es für die vielleicht nicht nochmal eng wird. Wie gesagt, wenn ich es mir aussuchen könnte, würde ich sagen, Sandhausen und Regensburg können da bleiben, wo sie stehen. Und der Rest wird sich irgendwie retten.
Also zwei Unentschieden waren es. Aber für Hannover kommt jetzt dann eben das Spiel gegen Nürnberg und dann das Derby gegen Braunschweig. Ich meine, Annas Meinung zu Hannover müssen wir da jetzt nicht einholen. Vermutlich kommen wir uns zumindest… Genau, so ist es. Richtig, da bin ich eine Zeile verrückt. Danke, Olli. Moritz, du kannst ja am entspanntesten von allen draufgucken, aber hast du Gedanken zu den Sachen, die jetzt Olli hat? Es war ja wunderschön, Olli. Hast du sie einfach durch den kompletten Keller einmal durchgeführt, haben wir die volle Führung bekommen. Welche Ecken hat er noch nicht ausgeleuchtet, der Olli, Moritz?
Ich kann ihm bei einer Sache zustimmen, und ich weiß, dass dieser Satz, den ich jetzt sagen werde, gemein ist. Aber wenn ich die 2. Liga als Gesamtbild betrachte, dann verdrägt die 2. Liga nicht Sandhausen und Elbersberg.
Ist das nicht ein bisschen schwarz-weiß, denke?
Bei wem ich persönlich sehr skeptisch bin, ist der 1. FC Nürnberg. Ich drücke ihm natürlich die Daumen, dass er in dieser Liga bleibt, weil der 1. FC Nürnberg – ich hoffe wirklich, dass ihm dieses 3. Liga Bad davon verschont bleibt. Aber ich sehe da so ein bisschen, wenn man sich die Vergangenheit anschaut, natürlich auch die Parallelen, die der FCK irgendwo mal durchgemacht hat, mit größeren Ambitionen und seine Ziele Jahr für Jahr verfehlt. Jetzt haben wir diese Saison mit dem zweiten Trainerwechsel. Wir haben über die Art und Weise der Trainerwechsel gerade schon gesprochen. Ich glaube, die Entscheidung zu Markus Weins hier würde Dieter Hecking jetzt mit dem Wissen von heute auch anders treffen. Ja, es wird schwierig für Nürnberg. Ich glaube auch, dass jetzt – Freitagabend gegen Braunschweig, richtig? Das könnte auch schon so einen kleinen Fingerzeig geben, in welche Richtung es für die Nürnberger geht. Ansonsten, ich glaube, zum FCK brauchen wir da unten nicht mal reden. Also auch wenn dieses ominöse 40-Punkte-Ziel jetzt seit einigen Wochen nicht erreicht wird, runterrutschen tun sie auf gar keinen Fall mehr.
Was für ein absurder Satz eigentlich am 23. Spieltag. Seit einigen Wochen haben wir ja das 40-Punkte-Ziel nicht erreicht mit dem FCK. Also das ist wirklich – ja, man auf dem allerhöchsten Niveau. Aber das weißt du ja. Anna, wie blickst du auf den Tabellenkeller? Du darfst doch gerne über Hannover 96 sprechen. Wir wissen ja, dass uns bekannte Hannover 96-Fans sowieso jetzt zuhören, weil du hier zu Gast bist.
Ja, ich wohne ja in diesem Hannover. Das wissen wahrscheinlich auch die meisten. Ich habe ein durchaus ambivalentes Verhältnis zu dem Verein, weil natürlich ist es der ewige Derby-Gegner. Und ich pflege diese Rivalität auch gerne persönlich, traditionsbewusst und leidenschaftlich. Auf der anderen Seite gibt es ja in meinem privaten Umfeld auch Menschen, die ich gern habe. Die 96 Fans sind so eine kleine Schnittmenge. Und denen wünsche ich diesen Kummer wirklich überhaupt nicht. Nichtsdestotrotz, bei aller Folklore, ich verstehe schon den Gedanken dahinter. 96 hat zwei Unentschieden geholt. Die Stürmer sind in der Formenkrise Ziele, ist nicht so gut wie in der Hinrunde. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das nicht besonders rühmlich wird für den Verein in der Rückrunde. Vor allem, weil sie eben kein Ziel mehr haben. Die werden nicht mehr aufsteigen. Ich glaube, der Kader geht auch 200 Prozent davon aus, dass das nicht passieren wird, dass man da unten ernsthaft nochmal wirklich in Gefahr gerät. Also, für was genau soll man schwitzen am Spieltag? Ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass das zu diesem Zeitpunkt in der Saison einen relevanten Unterschied machen kann, diese Motivationsfrage. Nürnberg finde ich den noch besseren Pick aus dem Grund, weil ich glaube, dass diese in Anführungszeichen großen Vereine im Abstiegskampf einfach sehr unter Stress stehen. Deswegen würde ich auch Arminia Bielefeld mal schauen, was der Trainerwechsel in welcher Richtung bewirkt oder nicht bewirkt. Aber sie sind gerade aus der Bundesliga abgestiegen. Da kann sich das Umfeld auch geduldig geben. Ich denke schon, dass man da insgeheim andere Ansprüche hat, wenn man von oben kommt, als sich mit der 3. Liga auseinanderzusetzen. Und mit diesem Druck umzugehen, dafür ist nicht jeder Spieler und dafür ist auch nicht jeder Kader gedacht, weil sie auch nicht dafür zusammengestellt worden sind. Ich denke nicht, dass Hacking den Kader zusammengestellt hat, in dem Bestreben, irgendwie die Klasse zu halten. Und das kann dann schwierig werden, wenn diese Typen auf eine Situation treffen, in der sie sich nicht wohlfühlen, weil sie sie nicht kennen. Was wiederum der komische Vorteil von den beiden aktuell Letzten sein könnte. Weil in Regensburg und Sandhausen man eben einfach so in Ruhe vor sich hinarbeiten kann. Ohne dass es richtig viele Leute stört oder freut. Wir Braunschweiger werden bis zum Mai da mit unten rum schwimmen. Da bin ich leider relativ sicher.
Und ist das nicht krass, dass wir jetzt über den Abstiegskampf sprechen und St. Pauli gar nicht mehr nennen müssen, weil die halt einfach in sechs Spielen der Rückrunde einen Punkt mehr geholt haben als in der kompletten Hinrunde. Und jetzt im Grunde auch so gut wie raus sind mit 14 Punkten Vorsprung. Die haben ja das gemacht, was alle sich immer wünschen. Einfach quasi nochmal mit einem neuen Kartendec starten und dann durchziehen. Aber das ist schon wirklich verrückt. Und da wollte ich nochmal kurz darauf hinweisen. Falls ihr das nicht so genau mitbekommen habt, liegt daran. Die haben jetzt einfach alles gewonnen. Auch neue Trainer und so weiter. Kann also auch funktionieren.
Habe ich gehört, dass sie es normalerweise andersrum machen. Oder andersrum. Letzte Saison war es, glaube ich, so. Da haben sie ja in der Hinrunde alles kaputt geschossen. Waren, glaube ich, sogar Herbstmeister, weiß ich jetzt nicht. Aber auf jeden Fall oben richtig gut mit dabei. Noch bis in den März, April rein. Und dann plötzlich da irgendwie den Halt verloren. Dann gefühlt kein Spiel mehr gewonnen bis Saisonende. Und das dann diese Saison erstmal weitergemacht. Einmal den Trainer getauscht und plötzlich fangen sie wieder an zu gewinnen.
Das ist der Fluch der Halbserien, genau. St. Pauli, letzte Saison mit 7 Punkten Vorsprung. Damals auf dem Relegationsplatz ist man tatsächlich Herbstmeister geworden. Naja, aber immerhin, Abstieg wird es nicht mehr. Wir grüßen sehr herzlich alle St. Pauli-Fans. Und wir werden uns angucken, wie sich das so weiter in der 2. Liga entwickelt. Mehr oder weniger entspannt. Aber ihr habt ja im Grunde schon alles dazu gesagt, was man wissen muss. Ich danke euch dreien sehr, sehr herzlich. Das hat große Freude gemacht, mal ausführlicher auf die 3 Aufsteiger zu gucken. Wird mich auch interessieren, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wie ihr das jetzt gefunden habt. Wir haben es jetzt diesmal ein bisschen anders gemacht, diesen 2. Liga Kurzpass. Gebt uns gerne Feedback dazu unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de und im sozialen Netzwerk eurer Wahl. Und jetzt danke ich sehr, sehr herzlich der Ed Rosa Laut, Anna Lautenbach. Man kann dich bei der Gegend gerade hören, werde ich alles verlinken. Danke dir, liebe Anna, dass du im Rasenfunk warst.
Danke für die Einladung, Max.
Das freut mich zu hören. Und schön war es auch, dass Oliver Leiste mal wieder hier war. Beim Neues vom Krügelplatz hört man ihn über Magdeburg sprechen. Als edleisteo kann man ihm folgen. Danke dir, Olli, dass du im Rasenfunk warst. Und danke an Moritz Kreilinger vom Kicker der EDM-Kreilinger, der total entspannt über der Liga thront und sich wundert, warum diese Visionen auf einmal alle so positiv sind. Danke dir, lieber Moritz, dass du hier im Rasenfunk warst.
War ein schönes Gespräch mit euch.
Ja, das fand ich allerdings auch. Und ich hoffe, die Hörerinnen und Hörer auch. Hinterlasst uns gerne Feedback und hört gerne im Rasenfunk rein. Und unterstützt den Rasenfunk. Der Rasenfunk ist werbepaywall und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns und auch die Gäste, Honorare, die wir zahlen, ausschließlich über eure freiwilligen Zahlungen. Und das, was ihr uns gebt, das geht unter anderem in Annika Becker. Die soll zur Frauen-WM für uns reisen nach Australien. Also es gibt mehrere gute Gründe, uns zu unterstützen, auf rasenfunk.de. Support das Club, erfahrt ihr genau, wie es geht. Danke an alle, die das jetzt tun, nach diesem Aufruf. Und dann hören wir uns bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Bis dahin, bleibt gesund, macht's gut, ciao!